hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now in the past few episodes that we've
done if this we've mostly just explored
the depths of our own insanity and what
we discovered is we're pretty dang
insane as I said that good notice I
didn't say intelligent I just said
insane but we're gonna explore further
the reasons by which we stand in order
what we're gonna join a club basically
so let's do that
and not make a fool of ourselves in this
ending welp that was wrong button there
we go
alright only boring girls well if
there's one thing that is it's boring
I'm not talking about me in the game I'm
talking about markiplier here ah ooh
must be sweet just like strawberries and
I gotta get my gear I forgot everybody
happy okay good
hi welcome everybody who the [ __ ] are
you I mean I'm not one to question
people's normal morality hello who how
are you are you my rival who the hell I
can't even talk to you I can't even look
at you what are you doing who are you hi
oh don't smile like that friggin weirdo
friendly but strict I thought that was
the name Kyoshi tie so gym teacher gray
don't give me that look oh god stop
checking me out like that
I mean I know I'm gorgeous but frankly
you're creeping me out
where's senpai he smell good today
that's a nice Musk okay I'm gonna go on
my way now bye senpai have a lovely day
at school whatever it is you do while
you're here the first Club that we're
gonna join because we're preparing for
the life of when we finally marry senpai
and get to be able to provide for him as
a wife not in the counselor's office
that comes later but right now while the
marriage isn't on the rocks we're gonna
join the cooking club
hello robo I would like to join
yes because the cooking club is the
first way to win the hearts of all your
friends and they are your friends no
matter how much they scream they're not
anyway oh look at me I'm freaking
adorable with my little bonnet okay
so the good thing about this place phone
steel phone stole my own phone I did it
it's the little victories that I need to
congratulate myself upon because
otherwise there's no joy and only murder
ha ha ha ha so as you can see I'm
shoving a knife and a hot dog and
turning it into something adorable if
you can see that it's adorable I've got
a plate of little itty-bitty octopi look
at you look at all of you oh that's
adorable
oh I even smiled what is this I have
emotions I was not made aware of these
emotions what are these feelings
fluttering in my chest oh it's a heart
attack senpai I'm gonna do it oh [ __ ]
can I not pick that up no ok well then
send bye don't you want my lovely
sausages damn it senpai
goodbye forget to pick this [ __ ] Oh No
give me that I thought it was lost to
the winds
hey boobs McKenzie there you are hey
you're my bro whoa ok this is a great
view of the locker oh boy we're just
gonna assume she ate it I mean what else
we can assume she shoved never mind
enjoy again I don't see anybody actually
eating these it's gonna hurt my feelings
if you don't take my food and put it
inside you
okay so as you can see my reputation is
skyrocketing I'm generally enough you
better eat you little [ __ ] you say
you're full oh it's one little hot dog
what are you gonna say that or filled
you up I'm gonna start to think you
didn't like it I'm gonna start feed you
didn't like it at all
boy you're next sure looks right for the
slicing I know how to dice pop your head
off and turn it into an octopus breath
what are you looking for some spicy
sausages I've got some you want why
would you do that I'm just trying to be
your friend Oh girls how's it going you
want some spicy dogs jeez no scram I
will not I will give you know what about
my Duggars oh come on there are little
octopuses okay goodbye well I'm gonna
get out of here you all have a lovely
day or am i I'm coming for you girls I
needed to get my sausages ha ha here we
go this is the martial arts club and the
martial arts club allows you to win any
fight what brings you here I'm sorry but
you can't be a member of two clubs at
the same time you'd have to leave your
other club in order to join us
hey I'm leaving your stupid Club thank
you
i'ma join ask is that you show up at
least once a week well that's good
because it seems to be exactly one week
until I fall over and die in this game
or everyone else does one or the other
I'm not
you seem like a prick goodbye I'm gonna
change oh oh so I was naked for like
half a second it counts okay so what I
can do now is I can win any fight with
the teacher or student and I'm assuming
this means I can win a fight with those
douche bags outside the school I'm gonna
show them what for not accepting my
spicy sausage not eating the hot dogs
that's what I wanted to show you
besides my sweet moves I was trying to
do something happen right there why did
you do that you son of a [ __ ]
um I don't know how yeah I thought I was
pretty sure looks pretty sure that I
thought that's what the someone lied to
me I'm gonna sneak up on you just let me
slide on in here let me just take a good
gander at the nape of your neck yeah
you'll never see me now
whoa even more stealthy you can barely
see me but twixt her legs ah I am the
epitome of stealth and I just crawl
under her desk no one will ever suspect
the murderous rampage er that is me here
we go ha ha oh no you know I was trying
to think wow she plowed me right through
the wall oh well I don't mind being
sliced at the midsection if it's at the
hands of a beautiful teacher I should
stop talking all right so that didn't
work
apparently the martial arts club isn't
as good as I thought it was maybe it's
because I haven't learned anything so
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna learn me
something unless that's a lie and
fuck'em like to think a little fart
happening every time I look there like
now that you had a lovely day of doing
club activities you are ready to be the
true yandere that you always knew that
you could be which is pointed that's
right not just [ __ ] around here I'm
trying to prove some show you in hope
this was let's plays are aren't they no
oh God hello hello yes let me it's the
gaming club I have joined Club and what
join club do is it gives you a whole
slew of things here this one you can
raise your stats that normally take a
long time for you to learn in school but
this one at the end here was apparently
a mystery I don't know why
don't mind me standing just flipping
through everything but this one's the
only one that's important so I can boost
my the chemistry right away and I don't
even need to wait around for it I don't
even need to sit down for it and then I
can go right to the chemistry lab which
is yeah okay so now now I just need to
go to my class my teacher and then what
I'm gonna do okay so now that everyone
goes to lunchtime all I have to do is
wait around for boobs McKenzie to appear
in the courtyard trying to eat a very
peaceful lunch but little does she know
that I exist and just like senpai who
doesn't know that I exist either
they won't see what's coming for them
for the case ascent by it's true love
for this case of boobs McKenzie it's
true dat
both are good except for the death it's
not good oh hi senpai oh are you a part
of this oh yes oh my god the way you sit
down and look at things and I got to do
my hair real quick oh don't look at me
I'm hideous of course you never say that
wick you can buy
would you hey hey oh there's someone in
my picture I can just barely make out
their boobs Kenji I will devour you you
flattered I know I keep using the term
[ __ ]
I know you notice how I feel about you
okay I've made up my mind I'll tell him
how I feel this Friday you deserve what
I'm going to watch very closely yeah
this is exactly what I need to remember
you by
see oh shut up I'm gonna take one
picture of her all you see is her boobs
oh oh whoa well this don't seem good huh
did something happen to you oh no
Karma's a [ __ ] oh no oh no oh no it's
my victory crawl don't mind me Oh senpai
so long as you don't look at mediately
to your left
how you doing hey certainly not a
murderer walking away from the scene of
a crime
oh hi what are you doing
mmm yeah pose for me that's good over
the dead body passage oh look good for
me well alright then I don't know what
you're doing
oh god stop dancing on the bodies of the
dead it's awfully inappropriate you know
what I'm just gonna let you do your
thing because frankly I don't have the
time or energy to deal with it so thank
you everybody so much for watching this
has been yandere simulator there's a lot
more clubs and a lot more updates that
happen to this game very regularly but
the developer has said that the next
updates are gonna take longer cuz
they're gonna be more involved so expect
some cool things so let me know what you
want to see in the next episode of
yandere simulator and as always I will
see you
in the next video